I'm finally hitting my stride did you
see me nail that airplane turn when I
popped out of the glades on the left
there you're like a little Picabo Street
it's super impressive really I feel like
my runs today have been closer to the
emotional rawness of Alex ability yes
I'm crushing it at my activity I may
have to dip into my quiver and bust out
my are modest to do some real news bro
look how close I'm getting to my move go
can you scroll in a little knob to see
how many face plants you had today it's
in digital crown bro did you even watch
Johnny Ives video can't wait to check
out the playback tonight on my GoPro
view just okay I told you it's because
of this board the bindings are like
totally misaligned maybe you shouldn't
have thrown a fit at the rental shop
about them not having Apple PES 2014
Gary I don't carry a wallet anymore
oh my god oh my god Gary the bartender
from chair 9 just texted me if I can be
there in 10 minutes she can get me
tickets to the Solange Knowles DJ set
tonight at beli oh that sounds
terrifying her my heartbeat as a thank
you lily and he's sipping hot toddies
with the local rope remember I said hi
to Solange we were renting our gear yeah
and her bodyguard strong arms you into
that rack of Moncler Jack and Oh bro I
could totally tell by the way she was
peeping the milanese eyes crossed my
wrists that she like definitely wanted
to retweet me what ice mesh magnetic but
infinitely adjustable why you whispering
5 minute precision what are you talking
about in a function I'll stop whispering
large life-changing evidence what what
what's happening
don't worry someone must have Quinn dit
when they were getting off the low no no
honestly being stuck in a chairlift is
one of my favorite things about skiing
that dead quiet you really feel the
weight of the snow just floating above
the treetops and looking around i'ma
grab a tree let slide down no that's a
terrible idea
Oh do not I repeat do not rock the ski
chick Oh perfect think I do here I need
to get off the ski lift like immediately
are you injured I took a little spill
earlier I'm usually like a super solid
border but can't evacuate unless there's
been an injury bro you don't understand
Solange Knowles is my friend DJ said it
belly up it's gonna be extremely
excellent okay
yes so you know bro I'm an internet
personality and like a lot of people are
counting on me to be at the show tonight
especially so on wait bro I totally
recognize you and your face scare the co
Empire expands you were the guy that was
shredding on the Freestyle course
earlier 1 2 super gnar gnar moves on
those sticks
oh oh yeah thanks that fakie to invert
whoa ok excuse me stop complimenting
there's important things to be done calm
down
I have no choice whoa halt do not lift
that bar broke Ikhwan just like the
hello ski and training dropping into the
untouched powder of blue river BC I
don't think you should have to Gare
solange is expecting I wasn't finished
I don't think you should jump until I'm
recording you should definitely jump
gross I need you ASAP at Ajax Express
and put oh I'm gonna drop in just fine
there's no need to call but that's sick
dude from the Freestyle course earlier
thanks okay okay three two oh no oh my
god this is excellent I just got a
notification I felt it the taptic engine
it's the bartender yeah gotta get down
the we don't do it Oh Garrett Garrett
unclip me no you're gonna like your neck
I dare you know what this is on you cuz
you've given me no choice here no Quinn
I gotta get to salon she just clipped
your leg hey man quit oh this one's
really hard to cut through Oh God
oh my god my claw is stuck on the bone
oh let's just say I've gotta use the
serrated edge you can see inside of
there and I like sawed it off I'm gonna
puke bro let's leave brush here
ah this is this is getting really nasty
oh my god I can't I can't look got to
get down the mountain just need her to
tweet my latest video need more likes
please
Solange anyone Oh sick I just shattered
my move goal